I have you heard of a big delay in as a Chinese herb for cancer also is the oil. Okay, I there's many different Chinese herbs that I haven't gotten into for cancer and it partly has to do with the purity and quality of those herbs and how to be able to obtain those.
So there are some of the Chinese herbs that are herbs that we use in our herbal different herbal products, but they're a different name. There's a lot of the Chinese herbs are herbs that are solely Chinese herbs that are herbs that are used in in really very many other countries and certainly don't go to America.
So I against trying any of the Chinese herbs. No, absolutely not.
If you've been led to try one of those and we have a couple of patients, maybe that are on this call that are working with the Chinese doctor, acupuncturists that are getting Chinese herbs from them as well. So I have no trouble doing that.
Also is it the oil drops that you recommended from five CBD dot com. Yes, that is that is the five CBD dot com that's what I said, you could give it a try the gummies I had didn't work at all, maybe wired most of the time.
So let's talk about that. So if a person is doing gummies, this person is talking about using THC to help with paid and to help with sleep.
If so in general CBD and THC can be beneficial to decrease anxiety, decrease paid increase relaxation and help with sleep.
Now, now understand the difference between CBD and THC. So THC is the psychoactive component of hemp or marijuana.
So THC is typically from marijuana CBD just about any CBD on the market today is from him, not from marijuana. So hemp and marijuana are in the same family, but they are not the same plant.
hemp does have a little bit of THC in it, but nothing that would change your psyche in any way, THC from marijuana is psychoactive and it has other benefits.
So there's a benefit to both. If a person has high amounts of pain, but if they might be on some medication for pain and they're trying to decrease that medication, and they ask, should I, can I start taking high dose CBD to decrease the pain.
The answer is, in my experience, no, even if you take very, very, very high doses of CBD, it's really not going to cut the pain if you're on a pain medication.
If a person has very mild pain for muscle exertion or something like that and they take CBD, they might get some relaxation of the muscle and they might have a decrease in the pain.
But if you have pain from cancer, from a tastasis and you're at a point of having to take medication for that pain, CBD is not going to work.
Will THC decrease pain in an instance like that? The answer is, on many people, yes, but the form of that THC is going to need to be experimented with.
So the THC in different gummies is going to be absorbed at different rates. So when you take THC with something sweet like a gummy, you will absorb it very quickly.
And you'll get a spike of THC in the bloodstream, which a lot of people like typically gummies with THC are used recreationally for people.
Okay, so personally, if you were with me a few years ago, I think I shared on the Zoom call by experience with THC, which quite honestly was downright hilarious for everybody, but me.
So what I was super sick, I did the high dose THC in the form of Rick Simpson oil, which was not a gummy, it was, it's a paste and it's like a tar that's in a squirt tube like a syringe that you have to syringe out because it's literally like tar and you have to squirt it out under your finger.
You have to bite it off your finger basically because it doesn't dissolve in your saliva and you have to suck the tar off of your finger.
It's very, very high concentrated THC and I actually took too much and there's a clear story about that, but that's another story.
So that more of a THC in that higher concentration is used called that's called Rick Simpson's oil and that is used to kill cancer.
But it has the high degree of side effects making you so sticky loopy that you could you could regret taking it, but there's been tons and tons and tons of stories of people that have.
Quote unquote, put themselves into remission using Rick Simpson. So I'm not against using Rick Simpson oil by any stretch imagination. We just can't legally sell it here.
But we can talk about it.
So that's a choice now that's using THC for the purpose of killing cancer that's not using THC for the purpose of pain.
However, there's people that have been on Rick Simpson before had success and maybe their cancer is kind of raising its ugly head again and their pain is really bad and they'll use a little bit of the Rick Simpson oil, which is the tar THC high concentration THC to help with pain and they get some really for that.
Well, different people have different tolerance levels. I mean, I never trade drugs. I've never done recreational drugs. I've never smoked anything. I'm never, I'm like a complete novice of that.
So by story, taking too much of the Rick Simpson oil because it sat in the car on a summer day and I got home and it squirted way too much onto my finger and I took it.
And I was completely loopy and it was funny story was not a good experience. It made me not want to try that again.
If my cancer ever raises its ugly head again, would I ever try Rick Simpson oil again. I would because there is it. There's no, I mean, besides it making you feel weird.
It will be. It's it can't really hurt you.
Now, this person isn't even asking that question, but I just wanted to address this. We haven't talked about this for a while using Rick Simpson oil and or THC.
So this person is talking about using a much lower concentration of THC to help with pain.
So I gave this person this website 5cbd.com because this website sells low dose THC CBD combinations of different combinations.
And they have a license to do that. And you can buy it from them in every state, I think.
So you could order it online from them. They have I think up to 10 milligrams THC.
And it's always in a combination. So if you do it in a gummy, you're going to get a spike because with with THC is in a sugar.
You're going to absorb it very quickly and it's going to stay in your system a short period time. So you're going to get a spike of THC in your system.
And then people take it recreational in a gummy. They feel a loopy and fun. And I guess that's enjoyable to me. I was not doing it.
But I guess that's really enjoyable to some people and it's great. But I have had people use the gummy to help them sleep. They just want a spike of THC to calm their brain so they can fall asleep.
People react differently to THC. Some people it's going to make them, you know, some people only two milligrams is going to be perfect to help them sleep. Some people five milligrams, some people 10 milligrams. Some people can't do the gummies at all because they can't tolerate the spike.
If that's the case, then you should take it either in a oil and this company sells droppers in oil.
So it's not sugar and you'll get a slower curve of THC absorbing it'll stay in your system longer, but at a lower level and then it'll drop off.
So for this person who did not tolerate it, if you tried THC in the past and you didn't tolerate it, look at taking it in a different form. I took gummies before. Well, gummies are going to be in a sugar form. It's going to be a high spike in a drop.
Well, then try it in a liquid form that's in a oil or, you know, bake it in a baked good, but typically that's going to be a sugar or taking it up what's called a butter, which isn't a fat. So take it in a fat or eat some fat, some fatty food like peanut butter or something and then use a liquid dropper of the of that.
So you're going to try different forms. You got to experiment with it to see what work and you're going to experiment with what to see with the dosage milligram dosage will be best for you because honestly, it's different for everybody. Everybody's system is different. Everybody's tolerance to THC is different.
You're going to have to try it. But if you tried gummies and you didn't like gummies, you probably won't like gummies from any other source try a different.
In a liquid form, oil form and taking it with the fats, something like that.